joining us now our former chicago
blackhawks player kyle beach and his
attorney susan loggins kyle thank you
for joining us i'll start with you
now you said you buried this for years
in that it destroyed you why is it
important for you to reveal yourself
right now
thanks for having me on mate and i think
it's so important to me now because as
i've begun this healing process and i've
continued through this process
since i contacted susan about a year and
a half ago
it's been an amazing
uplifting experience
to share my story to be able to speak
out about my story to have other people
to talk about my story
and for me
realizing this and now looking back and
kind of going over my life over the last
10 10 11 years
there's a lot of things that i think i'd
like to have back and
a lot of moments that i've lost because
of i wasn't myself and i didn't have the
capacity to
to manage those situations
so for me right now it's important to
come forward to share my story because
this is so much bigger than kyle beach
yes i am a survivor but there's
millions of people in this world that
have been affected by sexual abuse or
sexual assault
and i'm speaking out now to hopefully
give them a voice to give them the power
to come forward so that we can make a
change in this world and hopefully make
this a safer place in sports but also in
work and life and every day
now kyle speaking of you not being the
only one the report alleged that brad
aldrich assaulted a team intern and then
three years later he pleaded guilty to a
sexual assault on a minor what is your
reaction to that
it makes me sick to my stomach
in the tsn interview yesterday with rick
westhead
who's done an amazing job on this from
day one
i broke down when he asked me if i would
have anything to say to that boy
and
my message to him was that i'm sorry
because i feel like
maybe i could have done more than to
protect
him at the same time i want to thank him
because when i found out his about his
story when i decided to google brad
aldrich's name after a teammate had
asked me about the incident
i found out about his story and it gave
me the courage and the strength and the
power
to ask for help and to inevitably
contact susan
and to be where we are today to make a
difference and hopefully send a message
to to everybody out there that you're
not alone
and that you do have power and people
will believe you
that's kyle i think what you're doing is
so important especially as a man because
there are so many stereotypes and i know
men who have been sexually assaulted
they feel like they should have had more
power that they should have been able to
defend themselves and i think by you
coming forward it is it's so important
to know
one in six people are sexually assaulted
um so thank you for doing what you're
doing right now you know the head the
then head coach uh joel quinnville
he's still coaching in the nhl what
would you have to say to him
hey i don't have all the facts
i have seen the report that came out
from the chicago blackhawks private
investigation and there's some pretty
disturbing
quotes
from the one in particular from stan
bowman
referring to joel quinnville
and a conversation that they had in a
meeting with several others that he's
quoted him as saying something along the
lines of
we can't deal with this now because
we're so close to in the stanley cup
finals
and that is absolutely the wrong message
and now kyle read that and to see that
it's very hard for me to believe
and i hope now
that i've spoken out that the truth has
come out that the people in the
appropriate positions will take action
and take the necessary actions to make
sure
that this is dealt with and that this
never happens again
now kyle
you mentioned that the necessary action
needs to be taken two top executives
have stepped down and the team has been
fined two million dollars do you feel
like more needs to be done within that
organization and across the league
i think more definitely needs to be done
amongst the league
um you know like i spoke earlier
the nhlpa was contacted don fear
actually released a message this morning
and i thought it was a great message and
i accept his message
i do believe that they want to do right
and i do believe that they will make the
necessary changes and i hope i might be
able to be involved in that
as far as the nhl goes
it's a very tough subject i lost one of
my friends one of my former teammates
not so long ago jimmy hayes
one of the best guys i've ever met in
the game
and i hadn't been in touch with him for
a long time
but from what i've gathered he needed
help and it never came
so whether it be with sexual assault or
sexual abuse or abuse in general
or drugs or anything else
i don't know when when is it going to be
enough for the nhl to step in
and say enough is enough and take the
necessary steps and take the necessary
actions to make it different and protect
the players that make the nhl what it is
kyle thank you so much i appreciate you
stepping forward in your transparency
your courage will help others do the
same